when I look at just one picture from
Simon stalinhog's Tales From The Loop I
feel like I've watched an entire film
in a single haunting image a novel's
worth of narrative seems to play out
just below the surface
if you've ever seen this Arc before
you've probably experienced this too
even if you didn't know where it was
from Tales From The Loop and its sequel
things from the flood or World building
projects set in an alternate version of
Sweden in the 80s and 90s in which a
gigantic particle accelerator buried
beneath the fields in suburbs begins to
alter reality in unpredictable ways yet
the story is so much more than a summary
can convey there's a reason why
stalinhog's work has been adapted into
an RPG a board game and even a
live-action TV show
it is a haunting atmospheric project
that swallows you whole and the more
scenes You observe the more you can
piece together the engrossing narrative
below the surface
so for this entry into the archive I
want to dive deep into the hidden lore
of Tales From The Loop and investigate
why the project has struck a chord with
me and so many others this video will
explore the art stalinhog has released
online but you can purchase the full art
book using the links in the description
now let's enter the world of Simon
stalinhag and discover the mysteries of
Tales From The Loop
the distorted timeline of Tales From The
Loop begins with the loop itself the
largest particle accelerator in the
world built to be so powerful it can
warp space-time constructed in the 1960s
the Loop's presence can be filled
everywhere in the surrounding Swedish
Countryside not just in Daily vibrations
in mysterious anomalies but also in
literal changes to the landscape while
the loop itself is underground
monolithic structures and heaps of scrap
metal connected to the facility
gradually overtake the region by the
1980s the period in which Tales From The
Loop is set the Colossal cooling towers
of the central reactor are almost always
in view with their green lights casting
in Eerie glow into the foggy Skies these
scenes while beautiful also invoke a
hard to place feeling of anxiety as the
looming structure is increasingly
overshadow the seemingly oblivious
townsfolk
soon various advancements begin to seep
their way into everyday life magnetrine
Vehicles crafts that can float thanks to
a newly discovered levitating Force
become increasingly commonplace in the
world of the loop in the coming decades
several thousand ton Freighters take to
the skies appearing in the far
background of various scenes their
artificial lights like distant Stars
the scale Echoes the megalithic
spaceships from films like Close
Encounters of the Third Kind with their
vast Landscapes of flickering light
yet there's a sense of quiet
unmistakable dread mixed in with the
Nostalgia as these ships cast a shadow
over scenes of ordinary lives stalinhag
seems to be telling us that reality
around the facility is changing with the
facilities in perceptible influence
leaking into all aspects of society
in magnetrine vehicles aren't the most
revolutionary machines breakthroughs in
artificial nervous systems allow for
machines that walk with a balance
typically only seen in natural organisms
factories produce multi-legged machines
for all purposes from forestry to mining
to Warfare
the region surrounding the loop becomes
a hub for unmanned units with strange
machines roaming the woods and back
country
like the towers and hover ships these
robots create a distinct feeling of
wrongness for lack of a better word the
land itself feels alien and unwelcoming
a place where the ordinary doesn't
belong
while Tales From The Loop takes primary
inspiration from 80s media aesthetically
the project also Echoes the enigmatic
70s sci-fi film stalker directed by
Andre tarkovsky stalker tells the story
of three men who Venture across a
mysterious restricted site known simply
as the zone at the epicenter of the Zone
there exists a room that can supposedly
Grant a person's innermost desires the
film is dense complex and endlessly
interpretable but one could argue that
above all stalker is a film about
atmosphere much like Tales From The Loop
the natural green Landscapes of the Zone
aren't what we typically associate with
sci-fi scenery yet threw wide shots in
the subtle presence of industrial debris
the countryside of the Zone feels
menacing and distorted but in a way that
is difficult to rationalize while
conceptually Tales From The Loop in
stalker diverge in various ways this
concept of familiar Landscapes rendered
unfamiliar through quiet abnormalities
is something Central to both works
but all the technology we've seen so far
entails from the loop is just the
beginning as the decade wears on
Whispers begin to circulate that the
facility is attempting to create
machines able to feel and reason some of
these prototypes even manage to escape
While others are disposed of
unceremoniously
Androids are machines designed to look
particularly human and many find
themselves rusting in forgotten corners
of the land just one of many strange
objects the Loop's operations leave
behind
and there are rumors of stranger
occurrences prehistoric monsters begin
to appear in the woods the results of
Eddie's swirling in space-time in the
wake of cosmic energies a bridge is
created allowing creatures from the
distant past to wander into the present
in one image a group of theropods roamed
the countryside near an empty road while
arching structures loom in the
background the feeling of out of
place-ness that these paintings evoke is
heightened as their subjects are out of
time as well
these dinosaurs have wonderfully retro
design sensibilities mirroring what you
might see in the original Jurassic Park
films or on Old School dinosaur posters
in another scene a group of hadrosaurids
roam through the snow near the rusting
shells of abandoned magnetrine vehicles
confused by this strange new land while
an exciting image there's also a sense
in pieces like these that the loop is
changing things forever that these
upsets to the Natural order might be too
great to be made right again
notably children feature prominently in
most Tales From The Loop images and
indeed the entire volume is positioned
as the childhood memories of the
author's Alter Ego a childhood near the
facility means these children are
exposed to many things beyond their
comprehension which they treat as
miraculous they don't understand how
irrevocably the world around them is
changing how could they
I think on some level Tales From The
Loop is a story about the cultural
memory of the 80s in which the Sci-Fi
imagery from that decade assumes literal
physical form
in this regard it shares a lot of DNA
with another 80s inspired film Pano's
cosmatoses Beyond the Black rainbow
released in 2010 but set in 1938 the
film focuses on a secluded research
facility called The arboria Institute
which houses all sorts of surreal and
unethical experiments over the course of
the film the protagonist a girl with
latent psychic abilities imprisoned
within the lower levels slowly becomes
more and more aware of the horrors the
facility really contains the Psychedelic
narrative moves at a deliberately slow
hypnotic Pace with much of the plot
coming purely from visual storytelling
the Retro imagery feels born from the
same primordial soup as Tales from the
loop with most scenes Awash with the
fused neon light yet well beyond the
black rainbow is ultimately a story
about the loss of innocent in the
destruction of childhood entails from
the loop the children never wake up to
the Terrors of the facility through the
lens of childhood the Miracles of the
loop or just that Miracles it's only us
the audience who are aware of how
dysfunctional things really are as a
result as unnerving as the art book can
get it never veers into a full-on
nightmare
probably because the real nightmares
show up in things from the flood
released two years after Tales From The
Loop things from the flood is a
follow-up art book that takes place in
the 1990s after the loop is supposedly
decommissioned but the strange
occurrences continue in things from the
flood the children are now teenagers
anguished over the disillusionment that
comes with growing up if the first
volume is like a dream the second is
like waking up and finding the world is
much less simple than you realized
things from the flood Begins With
Disaster the titular flood comes without
warning a leak from the innards of the
decommissioned Loop that floods
basements berries cars and leaves towns
surrounding the facility have drowned
the immediate effect following the flood
is displacement with the government
moving families whose homes were
destroyed into more urban areas further
away from the decommissioned Loop here
stalinhag brings to life a landscape of
exceedingly Bleak and impersonal Office
Buildings which have a disquieting
liminal quality some of these Urban
Landscapes feature colossal vertical
cities surreal Towers consisting of
numerous conjoined buildings the product
of a public housing program from decades
earlier
one noteworthy element that lurks at the
edges of these sequences are nameless
mascots whose overly cheerful and
commercialized nature contrasts bitterly
with the gloomy and dour Landscapes
their exaggerated Smiles reflect the
prevailing ethos around the loop that
everything is fine although their
expressions seem strained and unsettling
in such a grim World decaying mascots
that continue to smile despite the ruin
creeping in around them or a motif
present in stalinhog's art in general
and I think strike a chord with a lot of
people there's something fundamentally
mesmerizing about these images which
give the impression of a quiet dystopia
and it's not just mascots that help
create this atmosphere painted flowers
Adorn the sides of concrete blocks an
apparent attempt to make up for what the
material world is lacking at night the
city itself seems threatening lit by
Neon advertisements suspended above the
skyline by magnitude technology scenes
like this show hyper commercialism
creeping into the world of things from
the flood exerting an influence as
subtle and Insidious as the loop itself
discarded robots also feature heavily in
these illustrations rusting away in the
back alleys of the city
on the margins of urban areas a new
population emerges Androids fleeing from
Demolition sites settle in the outskirts
of the forests these displaced machines
are called vagabonds and are more
advanced than the prototypes of the
previous decade showing an interest in
colorful clothing and complex patterns
there's an unmistakable Despair and
Desperation to many of these portraits
of vagabonds a feeling that these are
intelligent beings pushed to the
outskirts of a society that sees them as
nuts and bolts these are machines
capable of the self-expression in
individualism we typically associate
only with ourselves yet according to
passages from things from the flood most
people think of these machines as a
nuisance or outright fear them
in truth their fears should be directed
elsewhere a sickness overtakes some of
the larger machines a kind of infection
that causes them to roam around like
queasy animals bizarre organic looking
gross begin to form on their limbs and
Joints soon the government is working
around the clock trying to contain these
nightmarish Rogue machines the official
explanation is that the neural grease
that allows their artificial nervous
systems to function has mutated
resulting in Grim looking but ultimately
harmless growths but if one reads
between the margins another story
emerges something from the flood has
leaked into the groundwater which react
to inorganic material in disturbing ways
for it's not just large machines that
the sickness is affecting in a striking
series of images we can see how smaller
objects made of plastic and metal mutate
into semi-organic forms in some pieces
it seems like something is growing
inside the empty husks and spilling out
through the cracks whereas in others it
seems like the objects themselves are
melting away into a living Mass there's
a real terror to some of these images
but also something morbidly engrossing
like the pictures themselves are drawing
you in closer asking you to ponder every
disquieting detail the objects chosen
are instantly familiar from our
commercial reality and yet they take on
entirely new meaning when presented in
this context
it's fitting that things from the flood
a story about growing up from the
childhood shown in Tales From The Loop
seems to take inspiration from much
darker forms of media aesthetically this
section seems to pay homage to the
bodily Terror of another 80s sci-fi film
David cronenberg's video Drome not a
work for the faint of heart the
disturbing cult classic follows the CEO
of a television station who stumbles
upon a broadcast signal showing various
criminal acts and begins to lose touch
with reality as the world around him
seems to become disfigured as is the
case in stalinhog's work everyday
objects begin to rise like living
organisms with the inorganic and
sanitized taking on the properties of
the organic and visceral to parse the
exact meaning from videodrome's Madness
would be an impossible undertaking in
this time frame but broadly the film
seems to explore floor concepts of how
violence intertwines with entertainment
and how humans can become desensitized
to visceral Horrors
you can see similar themes of
desensitization at play in things from
the flood as the public fails to
question the source of the mutations or
even be appropriately horrified by them
they've seen it all before life near the
loop is full of quiet everyday terrors
but in other images certain infected
machines seem to be evolving in some of
stalinhog's art from things from the
flood we can see almost entirely organic
beings menacing the countryside even
more so than usual there's an ambiguity
to many of these sequences one thing
seems clear however these fleshy
tendrils and strange growths are growing
Bolder in some compositions they seem
more like independent life forms than
parasites tied to machines
one of my absolute favorite pieces of
art from the things from the flood
series shows a small car Menace by two
massive beings the piece seems to be
related to the machine illness with the
creatures possessing similarly fleshy
tentacles but stalinhog doesn't reveal
the exact story behind these life forms
which is part of what makes the image so
engrossing as is often the case with
things from the flood the ambiguity
makes the World building all the more
intriguing
just how Tales From The Loop represents
childhood with its nostalgic atmosphere
and more innocent Viewpoint things from
the flood is a distinctly teenage work
all the way down to the uncomfortable
red pimples yet at the same time the
story is more than just Melancholy
showing the bright moments and growing
up as well as the dark ones
I certainly won't give away the ending
to things from the flood in this video
but suffice to say the narrative
continues to embody the theme stalinhag
established throughout his larger body
of work if you'd like to know more of
the specifics of what that entails
you'll have to check out the books for
yourself
Tales From The Loop and things from the
flood are both haunting and hopeful they
tell small ordinary stories in the
margins of massive world-shaking events
with solitary images and minimal text
Simon stalinhag conjures a world that
feels like looking into the future in
the past at the same time and if you
find this world as interesting as I do
you can purchase both art books using
the links below to get the full story
entails from the loop and things from
the flood aren't the only Incredible
World building project stalinhag has
created the electric state is a richly
detailed and Melancholy exploration of a
post-apocalyptic United States and the
Labyrinth is a darker and more
claustrophobic work of cosmic horror
I've got links to those in the
description as well
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video